foreign
[Music]
coming out day a day to celebrate and
spread awareness for queer people
everywhere this year some of our
favorite stars are taking part in this
special day in their very own way
including Madonna
[Music]
the global Superstar took to her Tick
Tock to shoot her shot so to speak by
attempting to throw some pink underwear
into the trash captioning the video if I
miss I'm gay and well take a look for
yourself
now I mean I'm no Sports expert shocking
I know but she did in fact miss that bin
fans have taken to Madonna's socials to
praise and congratulate her for coming
out though the star has not put a label
on where exactly she stands in the lgbtq
plus Community but we are just so happy
that Madonna is living her best life and
is able to express herself as a free and
open queer person
oh
[Music]
now Madonna isn't the only star to come
out this week as Shea Mitchell responded
to a tick tock claiming that all
bisexuals own a green velvet couch you
identify as bisexual
do you own a green velvet cake I love
knowing nothing about my life is
original you know and the coming out
does not stop there as Emily radakowski
responded to Mitchell's Tick Tock with
her own take
what a wonderful time for queer people
everywhere we are wishing a happy
National Coming Out day to Madonna Shea
Mitchell Emily Ratajkowski and to all
who celebrate
[Music]
hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos